i love your outfit i cannot get over i
mean we kind
of we kind of go together you know and
like a
big is it as comfy as i feel like it
would be it's pants right
it's super comfortable except to get
here i had to lay down
in the
how did you find shoes that perfectly
matched
well it's all votier my stylist ali
the genius um yeah she found this and
was like this is very you and i was like
i agree
it's very weird it's perfect for the mtv
movie and tv awards
honestly i've been living in jumpsuits
this entire year
so why not wear shiny aqua blue jumpsuit
i feel that how does it feel to be back
on a red carpet to be in person
after such a tumultuous sad
chaotic year oh i know it's been such a
tough year of such collective grief and
mourning and yet
a year i think in which we can all
celebrate
human will you know um and honestly it's
a bit surreal
i'm a little socially awkward right now
so forgive me
you know hi you know i don't really know
how to
how does he elbow we just stay away
still stay our six feet
yeah we keep it safe you are nominated
tonight you are presenting
tonight first of all what does the
nomination mean
oh it's so cool to be nominated for
lovecraft and for birds of prey to
projects that
mean so much to me and characters that i
just loved playing
and it's totally nominated for best
fight i love to kick ass
i hope you win tonight oh i'm sure you'd
say that's everything i know i haven't
said that one tonight actually
so this is not like i see you i do i did
see online that people are pulling for a
black canary
spin-off tv show oh
oh why are you smiling so big right now
you want it to happen it's amazing to
see the fans be so passionate and
and to see them accept the character and
root for the character
i i love black canary i love dinah lance
it's such an honor to play her and
i yeah it means so much to me that the
fans love it
could it happen have there been any sort
of conversations
listen it's above my pay grade i it's no
secret how much i love the character and
how much i would
love to continue playing her so talk to
dc
man you guys i i wish i had more say in
it
would it be a tv show or could it be its
own sort of standalone movie like
if you could fish your wish you are good
i just i love the character i was like
this girl is was born
what do you think what would you like to
do i think a tv show but i also like to
binge
watch things and i feel like you connect
more with tv okay
or at least i do so if i was in charge
of development i'm not
that's what i would do okay okay good to
know good to know
again i mean yeah if it was up to me you
know
yeah and and before i let you go i'm
getting wrapped you're working on lou
yes i just wrapped spider head um
which is a netflix film with chris
hemsworth and miles teller and now doing
about to do lou with alice and janie how
is it working with her
i she's a force they're not right this
is a totally different
side of she and i it'll be great i'm
very excited for you congratulations on
your nomination have fun tonight
thank you